au sol vérification mécanique avant
l'envol puis les premières figures dans
le ciel
en voltige aérienne tout se fait par
étapes questions de sécurité maximale et
ça commence dès l'entraînement ici neuf
pilotes se préparent pour les
championnats du monde de voltige
aérienne de châteauroux parmi eux et
revers tu ce pilote autrichien participe
à sa première compétition mondiale mais
après neuf ans de pratique il sait qu'il
ne faut rien négliger sur un avion il ya
toujours des petites choses et il faut à
chaque fois se presser la préparation
mentale et physique ça compte également
c'est ça la voltige aérienne
un ensemble tout se niche dans les
détails dans le cher deux aérodromes
accueille ses entraînements l'aéro club
de bourges est l'un des plus anciens de
france un titre qui n'empêche pas un
déficit de notoriété grâce à la présence
de ces pilotes et de leurs bolides
le site espère faire décoller sa
fréquentation grand public car
l'aviation cite aussi du loisir il ya
plusieurs disciplines dans le dans le
vol il ya plusieurs façons de se faire
plaisir
il ya le voyage il ya la découverte et
puis on va aussi à l'étranger on peut
aller en corse on peut aller au maroc
quand même peut aller en espagne on peut
aller n'importe où à partir de bourges
donc la pratique de l'avion c'est à la
portée de beaucoup je dirais pas de tous
mais de beaucoup la tête dans les airs
ses pilotes la garderie ici jusqu'à
mercredi
ensuite direction chapeau ou pour
d'autres entraînement obligatoire avant
le début de la compétition